hello everyone and welcome back to the
state of the web my guest is Colin
Bendel he's part of the CTO office at
Clair Denari and co-author of the book
high-performance images and today we're
talking about the state of images let's
get started thank you for being here I
want to start by you just talking about
some of the things that developers have
probably already heard about with image
optimization let's start with layout
stability what are some of the things
developers could do to eliminate that
janky Ness of image loading yeah so I
mean that's one of the one of the many
challenges we have with images and video
on the web right is that experience
where the user is engaging this in the
page and all of a sudden they go to
click on a link or scroll all of a
sudden everything moves and it's gone
and we talk about Jake a lot of times
because it's about JavaScript you know
filling that that buffer the in the time
loop can be able to do too much and you
can't do that and but image is also a
play in that because if you have the
browser has enough information it's
downloaded the CSS and and most the
JavaScript it needs as doing the layout
but then it's images are a low priority
request and so they they come in later
and as they're coming in if the browser
didn't already have a box predefined
then when the image finally comes in it
realizes oh this is a six by nine image
and then has to reflow everything you've
got that relay out and so there's a
number of strategies that we've used in
the web because ultimately we're trying
to stop the user from having a poor
experience right and we don't want to
distract the user from that experience
so we've used in the past things like
defining the height and width of an
image which is great in a fixed layout
kind of style and this becomes one of
those many different strategies of well
it kind of worked in the past but now
that I'm using max width and min width
I'm using responsive a responsive
layouts now how do I also define that
height because if I can't define the
height in absolute terms that we sell
how the same problem so some of the more
advanced strategies now using techniques
like low-quality placeholders where you
have a an image that maybe is
encoded in base64 so it's like a very
small image or maybe even an SVG that
gives enough information to the browser
early while it's doing layout to be able
to already define what the height and
width of that element is these are all
challenges with the browser and there's
later on we can talk about some of the
new enhancements like intrinsic sizes
and aspect ratio which are also trying
to provide us new techniques to give
that layout peace but ultimately you
know there's the the biggest boon for
your bit bang for your buck is to to
make sure you have defined those widths
and well quality play saw was a good way
to start with that and if we can you
know start to transition to intrinsic
sizes and things like that another
age-old battle developers have been
fighting with images has been the
balance between quality and file size
and the image format has been one way of
ensuring that you minimize the file size
so what is the conventional wisdom for
using the right file format almost every
day there's a new file format that's
somebody's talking about and we've got a
lot of great standby formats jpg PNG gif
I mean if you've been on the web a
search around for image optimizations
you probably have seen a lot of these
talks talking about these standard
formats any of the new formats like web
P or flyff or other standards out there
now the challenge is that each of these
formats have a different lineage
different history JPEGs been around for
25 years 26 years and it's a great
format because it's it does a lot of
great things to reduce the they the
bytes per pixel and give you a really
nice small image but it's designed for
photographically so inside that
photographic you are expecting to have
gradients of colors that sunset picture
or you know the the clothing they and
that's not always the case that you're
using so you have different formats
actually excel in different ways so you
have gifts and P and G's which are great
for probably more illustrations or you
know what you doing with pallets or
solid colors in large swaths
so that way you can in the optimization
of that that format they get looking for
those patterns and basically reducing
that the bytes down and so then you've
got a smaller image that way that's what
PNG but because of the where they find
those patterns varies dramatically
between these different formats and so
it really starts to come down first off
by the use cases
now what are you trying to do what kind
of content are you doing trying to
create icons illustrations are you
trying to do
photographic are you taking pictures of
for a news event or you know for dinner
and the picture of your of your plate so
the each format has strengths and
weaknesses to how you address it and
then you also can talk about formats
like SVG's which are great for vector
vector based imagery that can scale
based on the display area but you don't
have an exact pixel that needs to be
stretched or shrunk so those are the
format's we have but the challenge
always comes down to what does the
end-user support you know the the
browser or the app that they're
consuming this content fortunately you
know here we are in 2019 JPEG gif png
supported everywhere they've been around
for a long time and these libraries are
very old they're very robust but so when
we like to talk about new formats that's
the first journal is like how do we make
sure that they can be supported and then
how do they compare and performance wise
both in decode but also bytes savings
yeah and so they don't you know the
standbys are always the first place to
start and some of the features that you
may want out of your images like
transparency just aren't even supportive
in some formats well exactly right so
JPEG is great for a photographic but
doesn't do transparency where as gifts
can do transparency but single bit
whereas you can do with much large
better transparency with PNG so you can
do that than anti-aliasing with PNG s so
then you're also trapped with these
trade-offs of what do my trying to
accomplish and what with the best format
to get the light savings down it's good
to note it you know the
this paradigm that we're evolving into
you know we're in this Instagram age
right we've got lots of images
everywhere to grab our attention and you
know the it almost seems like images are
an old thing which solved this a long
time ago but yet it's a new thing right
we have this tension because we have
content creators who are trying to
create beautiful experiences and then us
developers are trying to like get a good
good score on lighthouse and get our
page performance down and and we have to
balance these two objectives in this
with just a format selection exactly so
once you've chosen a format what are
some of the knobs that you can fine-tune
to optimize image quality yeah okay so
the the standard was you poly CL law on
the web for JPEG quality index right so
you you change the quality factor and
you'll probably here use quality eighty
as a good now it's a probably good spot
to talk about when we say quality we're
not talking about percentage just let
people talk think no quality of 80% on
JPEG was actually it's a unit base of a
hundred in each of those hundred map to
a quantization matrix so you know it's a
it's a matrix that 8x8 matrix has
applied in JPEG world to this image to
try to reduce the number of colors if
you will in this block so if we can make
those all more whites the same kind of
white then we can easily compress that
those series of pixels out and we can
get better savings the more aggressive
that we can take the range of colors
down so quality index is in JPEG is the
one most people talk about right you
start with quality eighty quality ninety
you get a lot of bang for your buck on
average
now there's other strategies and we
could talk about other ones like using
chroma subsampling which is a strategy
where that comes from the TV industry
where you can take separate the colors
because your eye sees you've got cones
and rods and you are more sensitive to
brightness than you are about the color
itself so you
and say jpg you can not talk of it you
can express the bitstream of color in
instead just RGB you can do in ycbcr
that's like chroma which is the color
and luminance as the black and white or
they brightness so you chroma
subsampling is a technique where you
basically keep the grate the luminance
channel and the chroma you can share the
color and say a 2x2 grid share the same
colors put one pixel of color and though
and blending that with the black and
white or the the luminance channel you
get this it perceives like different
colors but they're actually the same
this is out all TV generally works as
how we we got color check TVs back in
the 20s is by doing this trickery
playing with our eyes and so JPEG can
support that P and G's gifts not so much
another one is is is progressive
displays so how you progressively
provide that content so if you do one
quarter of the image and then one half
and then you know full general terms
that those scan layers that they apply
they bring in the resolution of the
color of the image and by doing that
you're actually able to save some bytes
in that in those layers in the JPEG
world so if you were to start from
somewhere I would say start with these
three levers quality poly eighty or
ninety use chroma subsampling and again
we'll hope there's footnotes there and
and you know enable progressive on those
images so we should also talk about
mobile and how not only are there screen
size is getting smaller but also the
data plans are getting more expensive so
in what role have images played in
adapting to the mobile world I've been
doing a lot of research on my own about
the consumption habits by users and
looking at how they how do different
users in different environments consume
the web what kind of formats are
available and how's that and the
different experiences and I always had
this mental model of
mobile and desktop right and that there
is these two paradigms so these I and if
I track it by time of day I expected to
see like desktop traffic the traffic go
up in the morning people come to work
and then it to Peter off and the even
the afternoon evening as I go home and
then mobile traffic kind of carries on
it turns out that I was completely wrong
that in today's day and age what we see
is yes the morning 8:00 9:00 o'clock
you see traffic of desktop but Mobile's
always there and then in the afternoon
you have this decline you know five
o'clock slight slight decline but it
contains on all the way and mobile
continues on and bumps up so the well
first distinction I wanted to make is
that there really isn't a mobile versus
desktop world desktop is there is not
just a great box at our desk anymore a
mobile device includes our laptops which
we classify as desktop but is really we
carry that around on the subway and we
do work so the wider question I want to
make is that a desktop is actually a
mobile device so to your question the
real question you asked about is do what
should we do for mobile strategies well
the first place we start is of course we
should be dealing with responsive
layouts right using flexible grids and
then all the great stuff too to give
that consistent experience regardless of
your form factor whether you're viewing
it on a tablet or a phone or on a
desktop but this has a number of other
challenges because you now have a very
wide screen or very no portrait and
landscape challenges so where do I start
so the good news is that we've got you
know for a number of years we've had
support for responsive images so you can
use source set and source these two
attributes on the image tag with source
set allows you to specify to the browser
hey I have a number of different
versions of the same image that allow me
to define different break points so if
you have a wide image and you want to
say on a giant screen versus a smaller
screen it's the same image
I've got you know different pixel volume
so source that allows you to say have
got 200 pixel wide version a 300 of 500
a thousand pixel et cetera but the same
image just being you know resized the
other side at the other attribute we
have it's not an attributes an element
is the source element so in the picture
tag you can now have a source that says
I have not just one image here but I
have actually different cuts of that
image so I have the image that is square
perhaps in this layout but me I found a
wider version as well if I've got a
desktop view so what can I do with that
so you want to specify your media
queries and then you provide that
different context so you can have that
very fluid experience the same image but
instead of just resizing and making it
squishy and small but you get now maybe
different cuts from portrait to square
to letterbox whatever based on the
experience of the of the web you make a
good point about you can never really be
sure is a desktop device purely the gray
box sitting at home but like if I used
for example I use my mobile phone at
home on my home Wi-Fi where you know the
network isn't really affecting me so you
can't really make too many assumptions
about like well I need to serve low
quality images there on a small form
factor device it's not always true so to
client hints help it all here to
understand the context of the users
experience yeah yeah
so client hints is a strategy that
allows the browser to send additional
information along the wire to the
content servers and now this is at the
HTTP layer so you enable it through
markup or through HTTP headers saying
you know enable the client hints and the
different client hints that are
available today are with viewport width
and DP are so DPR is sorry to start with
with with is the relative to the
viewport so the viewport is the screen
width is the how wide is this specific
image so as I said B port width is the
actual screen size and then DPR is that
the density of the pixels
you have a 2x or 3x these hints when
they're sent across the wire in the
content negotiation allow the content
server to say oh I see you making a
request for this image I see that your
layout is you have 500 pixels wide for
this image I'll send you an image that's
appropriately sized the objective here
is that'll help save you with your
markup so you don't have to have you
know all the verbose markup that says
hey here's all of the different source
sets and all the different source
attribute elements you can now simplify
that down and let the content
negotiation define you know what should
I send to that that client know there's
a put a footnote here because client
hints has been around for a number of
years some great work that was done to
bring it to fruition but it also has
flag number of security concerns around
fingerprinting because those clients
were also being sent to everybody so
we've had some actually some really good
developments in the future policy spec
and when we're evolving client hints now
to be much more security aware in fact
it's going to hopefully bring us a spot
where we can be a lot more security
first conscious and actually help us
lock down the user agent because the
user agent such a terrible HTTP header
so this way we are able enabling the
developer to say these are the sites
that I trust to do content negotiation
where I want my images server or my
video server to actually be able to do
that negotiation for width and height
and DPR yeah but I don't want I don't
want those ad networks doing that and I
got control to make that decision of
what I trust because the opportunities
not just about providing the right
content but also using other details
about the environment that might give a
hint of how do we get content to the
eyeballs as fast as possible so if
you're using say network RTT or just
looking at congestion window these are
very low level tcp pete moments that
allow the server perhaps to
recognize that hey you're in a Wi-Fi but
you're in a hotel Wi-Fi and it's not the
greatest experience it's really slow so
perhaps a server can then say hey I want
to give you actually a half DPR image so
the pixels are gonna be half the volume
of pixels so I can send you across the
wire a much smaller file so I know it's
gonna get there and I'll let the browser
do that up sizing for you so that ya
client ins can help you in that that
regard help that content negotiation
back and forth images also play an
important role in accessibility and
according to the HTTP archive and
lighthouse also only about fifty percent
of mobile images have alt attributes set
so this is a drum we've been beating for
a very long time and it's kind of
surprising to hear that only half of
images are properly set up for this so
what do you think this is still an issue
we started off by talking about hey
there is this tension between content
creators and us developers the reality
is that when I'm building something the
the first the first user is me and so it
comes from my experiences that I start
from and the alt tag is a good example
of accessibility you've got image source
blah blah blah and then alt the alt tag
is used by anybody using a screen reader
and if you're using a screen reader you
don't have that alt tag you're gonna
have the the person with has visual
difficulties they're literally going to
be listening to the URL of that string
right terrible now
the alt tag gives that person the
opportunity to know that this is a you
know address with with sunflowers on it
right this is information that I care
about when I'm looking at it but the
challenge is that I the developer well
I'm fortunate enough to be to have good
sighted vision so I don't suffer from
this so it's hard for me to remember to
do you add the alt text of the
description attributes for the rest and
so unless you've got that direct
tangible experience
it's easy to forget so fortunately we've
got things like lighthouse that have the
accessibility scores in there that to
help remind us but it's it's a challenge
now there's actually some cool stuff you
know there's a canary version of chrome
that Scott that has machine learning
generating some of that alt tags I think
we're seeing some really cool stuff
coming out on that angle to help with
the accessibility but even a machine
learning based system that's going to
generate tag you'll say that it's a
dinosaur on a skateboard well is that
really what it is it's still best to
have that content for you it's a good
safety net but developers should still
be providing that alt text if they can
absolutely and so when we talk about
images in video there's actually a whole
spectrum of that experience right so
it's not just about the alt text like
why we're doing that all because we want
to feel warm and fuzzy inside well no
we're trying to get for accessibility
and actually it also helps with SEO and
discoverability so there's there should
be a lot of people championing for this
but there's you also should be thinking
about the the experience as a whole
because we're dealing with eyes that are
making decisions you know it's our
lizard brain if you will right like
we've got these cones and rods that go
straight to our visual cortex in the
back of our head and then it wakes up
our mammal brain and says hey you want
to pay attention so we're creating
visual content experiences on the web to
attract you to get that hook right - -
to get above the noise of the web but
our eyes aren't all the same right some
people have you know color blind right
they have which were taught in school
that we've got three cones some people
only have two cones or have two into
three cones out a little bit less right
so that's where you get the gradients of
red-green color confusion but there's
also a percentage of people particularly
it's women that have four cones that can
actually see more colors now the
interesting bit about this is that all
of our physiology invest in research is
all you know particularly around vision
is all based in the 1940s 50s 60s as
Purdue predominantly dudes that did all
this research and depending on who
you're looking at there's there's
different people that will say well
maybe only 12% of women have this fourth
chroma some will say that there's up to
50% of women so we have this other
aspect here of visual experiences that
are different based on some possibly
gender and there's just no research
really do to really say how much that
really makes a difference but it does
make a difference in when we make some
of our decisions so I said you know use
eighty percent eighty quality factor and
JPEG I take that back
because that's that's almost a terrible
choice because if I'm saying quality
eighty I'm assuming some editorial
control but I'm a I'm a dude that has
spent my time in front of a front of
code and I've not spent my time learning
or listening to my lizard brain learning
how the creative expression works and so
I can very easily make a poor choice by
saying qualitative that will actually
wash out those Reds that a person who
has better better apparatus than I have
would actually make difference be able
to see the difference between those Reds
and say no no that's not a good read and
if you look at it's actually there's
very few textile websites out there that
offer feedback there's a few out there
that do Lululemon is an example where if
you look at the comments the most common
recurring comment is that the I love
these there's clothing but the color
wasn't what I thought it was or you know
and it's always what the colored it's
not exactly what I expected it to be and
you know there's this downstream impact
you know they're returning products and
things like that but we expect that the
image to be representative reality but
if we've got people making decisions
that same quality that water waters down
those
then that experience could be diminished
so we have to be conscious of this so
the fortunate thing is that we also have
a lot of algorithms now that can help us
to find the right right combination of
chroma subsampling or whether it be
quality to equality factors and decide
what's the how do we preserve that
experience using structural similarity
as I am based algorithms that try to
make it more of an equation based and
more math driven that look at the
experience and you know the the emerging
ones also looking at the colors as they
as a part of that input so that you can
have confidence that I'm yes I want to
reduce bytes but I want to make sure
that it meets the expectations of the
content creator so the accessibility is
one aspect of it but also the the
emotional experience we're trying to you
know grab that user and bring them in
and and get that experience consistent
that's such a great example about the
shopping cart thing because a user may
look at a color in an image and not
expect to see it come arriving at their
house a totally separate color so the
way the developers actually fine-tune
their image quality doesn't just save
bytes on a wire in dollars and egress
costs but it actually could incur cost
in return fees and bad reviews and
there's a real monetary cost to that
absolutely I would love to be able to do
some research on this is you know one of
those areas I think we haven't explored
enough is like when we you know in the
real world so many times we we walk down
the street and we we'd walk by this
fruit cart and also we stop with like oh
yeah I actually I would like to have
that Apple it's really I like make that
choice I like to buy that Apple and I
was actually hungry yeah I didn't know
about it but I was hungry we're making
these decisions because of the that
lizard brain right now seeing the
environment when we have the right
combination of colors and experiences
those decisions now alert her so if I
have the web without images be very fast
but we probably wouldn't see anybody
actually engaging in your content
because
the hook isn't there and a content
creation teams have spent their entire
career learning how to get that hook
that emotional that matches reality I
want to ask you about web P it's been
around since 2010 but I'm ashamed to
admit I haven't quite adapted it so what
do you think is the current advice you
would give to somebody about web page
should I be using it it's been around
what's its twenty ten or so it's a great
format that has hit the web in the
absence of other formats getting large
traction and long as I mentioned earlier
there's a lot of different competing
formats out there but web P I it was a
supported by Chrome and predominantly
and more recently now we've got Firefox
and edge that also supports Chrome I
certainly support web P now web P is try
to learn from the past learned the
techniques that we've developed over the
last 20 years and be able to you know
apply new algorithms that can save more
bytes and and so it's a really good
mechanism you know I've got data that
suggests that with JPEG we've got
techniques and with yes a Moz JPEG we
can save another ten percent of bytes
with web P depending on the size of the
image we can save it anywhere from 10
percent up to 30 percent bytes and it
does depend right so small images
actually we say you see that 30 percent
byte savings as you get to a larger
image it gets watered down so it's about
10 percent but you over what you could
do with JPEG so you that's some
significant byte savings across the wire
if you're if you're constrained on that
network cellular network then getting a
visual hook and find the person that's a
great win but it comes with some cons as
well right so JPEGs been around for a
long time as I said it's really fast
decoder so when we're dealing with web P
we have to deal with modern browsers so
we have to hope that everybody's
adopting the latest browser like you and
I might be the reality is that not
everybody does you know I still see I
still see a lot of Lotus Notes traffic
the people getting you know web content
in the browser and it's from Lotus Notes
or it's from an old version of Internet
Explorer or our old versions of Firefox
I there's a beer that's weird there's a
lot of stuff out there so the one part
is adoption the second challenge is of
course the use cases with web P we have
finally the ability to do transparency
and even animation inside of a so we've
learned those lessons from the jpeg days
but we are also constrained in two big
ways one is it's forcing chroma
subsampling that's what I was mentioning
about the the technique that we've
learned from the video industry is the
luma and the chroma and be able to you
know reduce an amount of chroma the re
you're hacking the eye you're removing
detail but you're able to get get away
with it but what what web P does is it
forces a four to zero
chroma subsampling which means that
there are many cases where it's not a
good choice to use web P for instance in
Asian markets in most times you'll have
an image of whatever commerce that
you're selling and you'll have the Alexa
graphical characters bonded to that
image over top maybe the red outline and
well those hard lines are very
problematic for chroma subsiding they
become blurry and they're not great when
you have that blurry effect so anytime
you have hard lines or illustrations
these are cases where web P just falls
down and doesn't support isn't doesn't
give us the flexibility that we need and
in the other gap is color palette color
space so in the web we've built the web
based on 1996 standards around srgb
you know we if we looked at the amount
of colors that the typical eyes like
typical quote unquote three coned human
eye can experience if we plot those
reddish greenish and blue cones we get
this you know you apply CNN's horseshoe
shape the XYZ
colorspace you know all possible colors
now it's not two-dimensional is actually
a three-dimensional goop but yet the
idea srgb was a standard established in
the late 90s that said we can represent
these sets of colors and the triangle of
colors and we can represent that on the
web and in LCD displays and so forth so
all the web's been based around this
srgb that it limits to 8 bits per
channel so yeah this 24-bit image of
color space that is really a fraction of
the full colors that you can actually
see so with JPEG there's some hacks you
can do to kind of get over that yeah if
you can you know beg borrow the pixels
in the index but you're still limited
your with what you're limited to this
srgb we can't we need to move beyond
that and to be able to support more
colors because if we're trying to get
that hook of that user we need to
represent reality and srgb is just a
small percentage of that overall now
we've got devices if you've got a modern
Android device or modern iPhone you've
got devices that can do P 3 P 3 is an
even wider set of colors both in the
overall sets of color but also the
discrete colors between and if you've
got a 4k TV at home you've got probably
rec 2020 with high DPR which is even
larger we're closing in on what we could
do with analog film back in the 70s of
the colors that we can reproduce still
not 100% of reality so we talked about
formats you know these these are some of
the gaps we've solved some and web P is
great and available a lot of browsers
but we have these other upcoming
challenges that we need to also solve so
yeah it's a the Internet is weird I
always say that yeah so you had
mentioned that web P supports animations
and that brings me back to the days of
like those blinking under construction
gifts that you'd see on the web
everywhere so we've obviously come a
long way but what is the state of
animations today and what would you
recommend for
want to use them yeah so animations you
know it's one spot so it feels like it's
been stagnant for a long time but
surprisingly it's not died out everybody
assumed like anime gifts are terrible
just put it out there like they're
terrible because they're large for a
very short clip of say a TV show and you
need to have the sequence of that like
you know you could be rocking megabytes
of data really quickly but they're
really good at expressing meaning and
intent that's why they're so popular in
social media platforms because you're
able to express an idea really quickly
and you've got the it's a it's like a
video but it's muted it loops it's got a
hold other different creative aesthetic
so but gifts are really the only option
out there and we've done a lot of hacks
to get you higher color palettes it's
not just 5256 be able to get the the
effectiveness of a larger color palette
even though it's not so there but we
still have now this challenge of there's
still really large images that with WebP
II yeah like learning from the past they
obviously brought in the ability to
support animation I say that 1.7
megabyte animated gif in a web peas
maybe about 300 300 K that's that's
pretty pretty awesome but you also that
only supports inside the chrome
environment last year Apple in WebKit in
the Safari 12 it brought in support for
image source equals mp4 so you can
actually ship an mp4 to an image tag and
get an animated gif experience where you
can have a HEFCE or an h.264 payload
inside that in mp4 it loads like an MP
like an image tag but it's muted and
it's loops and that's they you can take
that the advantage is there if you've
got animations that are more picture
based because you know have seen it and
86 for those are really good codecs for
for real life you know for for video
movies TVs that kind of stuff so if
you've got an animations that have have
that kind of content then you've got a
right vehicles that brings that 300k and
web P down to well maybe 50 K I and have
C in the contrast though you still have
these gaps of pallet based animations if
you're trying to illustrate the ionic
bonds between you know for textbooks and
things like that those cases actually
gifts might be still among the better
and web P are good for that with you
know with these video codecs they become
a little bit more blurry so maybe not as
good so there's still lots of room for
us to figure out how to best deal with
these different composites just one
little quick anecdote though it it's not
just those young kids with their
animated gifs I talking with a number of
even the ad tech industry you know
they're trying to figure out how to get
past people putting on ad blockers
because while it's a crappy experience
and in up the game and the quality of
the ads so that they're relevant and
people aren't less like in and there's
emerging research showing that yeah
animated gifs are actually really good
for conversions but it can't be too
noisy like too noisy really you know
disturbs people but cinemagraph see all
the subtle movements create great
engagement for the ad tech in fact it's
working great in even commerce you
probably see those like the girl with a
dress moving the dress so you can see
the color the light refracting a little
bit so I think as we can start solving
some of these the technology bits were
going to see the content creation kind
of explode looking for animations we
talk about animation as a as an image
tag the age-old of course recommendation
is is to use the video tags if you've
got an animation just convert it to mp4
and use a video tag I mean that's that's
probably actually the best way to get
get the mix of all worlds you don't have
to depend on Safari just to get the
image and they as an mp4 in an image tag
so if you can change your markup change
your templates to use video that's great
the challenge is that not everybody can
modify the markup right if you've got a
CMS system or if you've got some other
you know platform
then you're gonna have to sometimes you
have to live with the tools you have so
this is where these you know there's
different strategies we can play if you
can play with the mark-up then great use
the video you know make the make it
looping and muted but if you are bound
by the content or it's gonna be six
months a year before you can you know
get the next code release out there that
can do that conversion then you uh you
still have lots of other tools available
to you
one more HTTP archive stat you've
probably heard about two-thirds of the
average web page is made up of image
bytes so practically speaking if
developers do optimize their images what
types of impact on the user experience
could they expect to see maybe what
performance was yeah so this is a one of
those those areas that is a yes but no
you know we see the stats and we say you
know where am I gonna get my bite
savings to get my user engagement up and
how I get my like high score like I
score up and it's easy to say pick on
the the big bully on the street but it's
yes there's a large amount of bytes on a
web page that are dedicated to images
and video and animations that's because
we're trying to grip that user engage
that user because people don't read
let's be honest that you want to see the
content but I think I'm into this
earlier the that images are a low
priority resource in the browser right
so in the browser's parsing the HTML
it's going to go and look for all of the
CSS and JavaScript and is in the the
preloader and and if it finds images it
will make those requests in the network
but it'll put those as a low priority
request so that we get the CSS back and
we can do the layout so if you're gonna
save bytes on images most times it's
really the JavaScript are still holding
up the Train unless you've got really
tight CSS and JavaScript already saving
bytes on images will will not give you
the same kind of being like you know
chopping 50% of your bytes it's not
going to speed up your page 50% because
you usually have a lot of this
JavaScript there are there's a balance
counterbalance though the counterbalance
is that if you are a lot of times you're
handcuffed
to the system the solutions you have
saving bytes can actually help in some
situations where you have a lot of
JavaScript that's inject being injected
and tag managers and things like that
where the browser is actually getting
and confused and getting things out of
order I see lots of cases where the
browser is the preloader finds all of
the images first before it finds the CSS
and JavaScript ships those requests and
then realizes that there's more
JavaScript be load and has to wait for
those images to come across before it
can do the other work so in cases like
that where you've got the browser
discoverability problem you actually
there those the cases where you can
improve the base load but there's
another challenge another metric that I
think that we often need to look at
which is not just about the the raw time
to first byte or the time to time to
write interactive or they they the first
paint and things like that but it's the
how long does the user stick around so
if you know the best practices are
around you know making sure that images
are small or you know byte wise and we
are making sure CSS and web fonts and
things like that are discoverable and
loaded first but we want to make sure
that those images and video are loaded
so when the user starts scrolling that
that content is there right so the
balance we want to find is deferring
image lowing and there's a lot of
strategies to do that right from I
mentioned earlier our low-quality
placeholders we put a little SVG or
inline text to lazy loading which we
just use pure JavaScript and don't load
that image until the user actually
Scrolls
those are good strategies to make sure
the bites aren't plugging up the pipe
but you also then want to counterbalance
that with once the layout has happened
once you've got all the JavaScript you
want to make sure that as the user goes
to start scrolling and if they're there
you want to keep them there now you want
to keep the user going through their
journey so you want to then open up the
gate and make sure that those images
start to flow in after you've got all
the essentials
so this is give-and-take that you need
to adjust but don't expect the world to
move on those core metrics for image and
bytes savings it will depends on your
America but what you will see is by
optimizing those bytes is your your
sessions your user engagement as they
interact those metrics should start to
improve as well so what is the ideal
solution of optimizing the bytes with
the quality of images is it for people
to spend more time understanding all of
these different levers on their
configuration or is it you know we need
to rely more on computers and algorithms
to do the right thing what you said yeah
yes yeah this is the the challenge right
we've got a lot of different formats a
lot of different levers to use and a lot
of different contexts and the good news
is that we have a lot of developed
industry knowledge to run through that
rubric to evaluate the context of those
images so this is where we are really
getting good as an industry bailant to
classify is this a picture with or an
illustration is this got lots of high
action movement or low action movement
has this got lots of colors there's this
grayscale and from there you know what
is the right experience we're trying to
drive so you know should we use this
knob and this knob should we change the
quality low and quality high so yeah
absolutely we should be depending on
algorithms because if we're marking
changing our markup there's a lot of
different ways we can be expressing that
and there's almost a hamster in a wheel
effect where there's always another
technique that we can apply that haven't
thought about before there's a lot of
great tools out there that allow us to
to just do that automatically and you
can see that I think squash you know
there's a nice tool there you can you
can see how those you apply the
different checkboxes and apply if I want
to change it to Moz JPEG or whatever you
can see the impact but there's also
great great tools that will
do that for you that you can apply apply
that in your build chain apply that into
your CMS etc not to mention you're not
always in control over the images that
get loaded on your site yeah you don't
you're not always putting them on your
CMS sometimes your own users are
uploading them to your site for example
my avatar or something like you need
those algorithms to process images
outside of your control yeah and there's
you know there's a whole actually other
dimension here of like from a Content
reputation perspective from content you
maybe don't want to have on your
platforms for legal or moral issues
there's also security concerns
you know images and videos and things
like that have had histories of other
vulnerabilities there were they become a
vehicle for passing on a CVE where a
certain decoder for using imagemagick or
something like that could be exploited
with this certain kind of payload so
this is yeah absolutely where the
algorithms come to play yeah using
depending on algorithms would be my
number one recommendation for dealing
with qualities and format selections and
then as we move into the other domain
domains like adjusting for colors and
things like that that's where you know
need to focus your you should be
focusing your attention with your
creative teams yeah finally would you
recommend any resources for people to
learn more about image optimization
there's a lot of great resources addy
has a great site images guide has a lot
of great content there
yeah I've published a number of
different articles around the role of
client hints and some of the stats that
that we see there and the use of
animations and Safari and there's a
bunch of in the web dev site there's a
ton of great resources about different
strategies different tools you put in
the bill chain to kind of you know fill
that fill that flow well Colin this has
been great thanks for coming on the show
thank you if you'd like to find links to
everything we talked about check out the
description below thanks for watching
we'll see you next time
[Music]